what's happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
several trailers for black panther
wakanda forever today John how are you
I'm excited how are you sir hello I'm
going through puberty and I'm congested
there I'm doing fine we are not going to
the Black Panther of wakanda forever
Premiere we turned them down we said
screw that we're not skills it's
definitely that we were not invited we
we said no that's the narrative we'll go
with leave a like if you can so here's
how it's gonna work today is that we got
ourselves three uh spots here long live
wakanda Throne there's another one where
it looks like a camera recording inside
of a theater from what I previewed when
I dropped all three into a final cut but
haven't actually seen the trailers
themselves how we do this we just drop
them all in the final cut then I export
after we cover that then we'll check out
the featurette that they released as
well there's chapters if you want to hop
around either way let's get to it
[Music]
[Music]
he's our one
[Music]
that does look good
[Applause]
I need to know
I got the symbacco on an enemy
enemy I heard anime
[Music]
two messes
okay we're gonna talk about that yeah
[Music]
oh yeah yeah
Proto suit they came from the water wow
is that a whale that was a whale
[Music]
that can't be good no it cannot
and make of it the costume design looks
phenomenal leave it at this quality it
does shine through right
it's a sign of a good job
[Music]
have that name or flying
got a little feet wings
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] that looks awesome
very cat-like wow nice gonna be like a
movie about grief and also super badass
combination of filmmaking yeah the first
action grief epic this really feels that
way every fight scene will be
accompanied with ample tears I mean I
know people will be like what are you
talking about there's like a lot of
Revenge action thrillers out there you
know what we're getting at here it's
just some fun a very noticeable things
to pick up on or then the general
thoughts of just how awesome everything
looks especially with Namor I mean we
have we I feel like they're just really
confirming that sure especially with the
Blaster moment out of there the sonic
waves at least sure he designed that to
needless to say the two masks I don't
know if they're trying to hint because
it's in both of these spots I don't know
if they're trying to hint if it's just
her like
Batman's mask and now she's she has her
own or if it's an implication that
there's two either way yeah this looks
really really awesome and I'm sure
people are having a really fun time at
the movie premiere I imagine but I don't
care I let them have their goods no need
to say we like it now now that we're not
invited absolutely not in fact I hated
everything we saw yeah no this is really
cool I mean they have hinted that like
oh you know what we've shown on the
trailers who's the next Black Panther it
might not be what you think and it seems
like they are so indicating that it
would be sure that I wonder if they
either will do some sort of dual black
panther thing moving forward or if
they're gonna you know pull out a trick
on us and I don't know what that could
be but I like at least having the
ability to wonder about it while also
being very excited at the prospect of
seeing it maybe a couple suits maybe a
couple different people donning the
suits and maybe a debate over who really
maybe the movie will embrace the debate
you know that we've all been having as
fans and I think that would probably be
a smart thing to do because it's a very
realistic thing to have happen but yeah
the action like I love that wherever uh
Namor and his people seem to go the
action is informed by a nautical flavor
you have that big like water explosion
on the bridge which you know is over a
body of waters so that could just be a
byproduct of that but it seems like
there will be a definite Elemental
quality to the way they fight which I
think is really cool and exciting and
then I think that line about I need to
know if wakanda is an ally or an enemy
it seems like they're hinting that
perhaps it won't be a full-on villain by
the end of it all and perhaps throughout
the whole movie he's not going to be
portrayed that way too antagonist yes
for the story but that this day shows up
yeah yeah there you go then they help
the team up and find them yeah uh yeah
let's watch this feature right audiences
have embraced wakanda and black panther
and chat Wick he knew exactly what this
store what these images meant to the
world
absolutely we all suffered an incredible
loss when we lost Chadwick Chad was very
much our artistic partner I would spend
time with him just he and I talking
about where we want to see the story go
how much he admired to other characters
and the actors that portrayed them
oh that's great to hear story you were
all able to honor him together it was
really beautiful to come back to wakanda
and for us to be able to do it with a
sense of Celebration and passion yeah
there's so much in this movie is amazing
so many new characters to explore just
seeing the world of wakanda again and
then now we're going to this whole new
world underwater
was a character we were really excited
to portray in a film arguably one of the
oldest comic book characters at their
age mutant
to play a character like this it's a
dream he's the king of an underwater
civilization called talukan he is
regarded as a living God
no way
it is astounding
and so it just really felt like for all
of us to give it everything we have and
more
grateful and blessed to be a part of
this the actors we're filled with
emotion and passion I am queen oh [ __ ]
just kidding me again
nipple chills
all together we ended up using those
feelings to create something really
special
the action and adventure with the
emotional Stakes so high things are
happening up down and everywhere
I'm so excited about the world being
able to tap into wakanda again
how each character she just looks so
sweet yeah it looks like a true Epic
[Music]
it's by the world
I think you're doing that cinematic
no that's the thing is like the first
one definitely has epic qualities to it
but this feels like an epic I mean the
way how we've had all those debates
about like super huge Superman or
something
your boy Jim Cameron was Justin director
wants a chance to I mean
they're Pro they're probed into these
questions though and a lot of them
aren't don't keep up to date with all
there's they're baited there's certain
films that do come out and this looks
like one of those MCU films that is
going to be cinematic it's going to be
true Cinema
um at least I I hope so you know because
I do want my Marvel Easter eggs and all
that too I don't want it all but that's
one of those the thing about this film
is it looks like it's kind of doing it
all and then from there this is
everything that we kind of hope for like
the the cool thing about feature rets is
what you get a chance to hear is the
intent behind making it it's like
everything we've been saying that kind
of what we were joking about that it's a
film that's going to really deal a lot
with grief and that's why in terms of
film medium format it makes sense to me
to not instantly do your follow-up with
a recast to Chalo thingy I actually
understand the argument for that believe
it or not I I do get it especially for
comic book readers and such it's a
different type of emotional Association
when you're dealing with people in live
action versus uh you know drawings on a
panel that's why I think this film can
be something super powerful and moving
and then they segue into using that
emotion for something to expand the
world of wakanda and of course the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and then you
know like seeing everything with Namor
in that Underwater World you definitely
got the yeah they have to have some type
of where do you get the vibration
there could be reserves down there you
never know that's true because this is
territory
love this movie
This truly will be the Avatar of Marvel
movies this is the film you personally
would love I too could probably see for
a longevity perspective why recasting
might be uh alluring but at the same
time I feel like especially because
comic book movies do have the debate
that surrounds them that they do not to
be lurid but it is something of an
opportunity when something like this
happens to not shy away from the real
life but to add the real life the thing
that movies are trying to do in the
first place is just bring comic books to
real life you have something like this
that gives you that opportunity and to
make it resonant in a way that anyone
and everyone can tap into and it feels
like they're doing that in a very
respectful way this seems like a very
special movie given a very crushing very
sad but also very unique opportunity to
tell a story and to affect people and I
think it'll be just as vital as the
first black panther in terms of just the
turnout and the passion from all sides
of the story you know yeah definitely
alright guys well there we are black
panther O'Connor forever we are going to
an advanced screening by the way but uh
it's we're gonna we're definitely
watching later than a lot of other
people which we are grateful for I'd
rather go to there you know ask other
people because I was like yeah I'd
rather honestly do that all right guys
uh well leave your thoughts down below
and what you're most looking forward to
for Connor forever subscribe click the
notification Bell leave a like last but
not least let's do it
well Gabe are you male female I can't
tell either way you're getting a
traditional shout out here G stands for
Greg lover oh goodness that is correct a
stands for
absolutely awesome that's a double
helping b stands for bitchinator meaning
the most bitching person in the world
who and E stands for
effervescent because you just make me
feel all bubbly inside like a Cherry
Cola oh that's so nice dude Gabe thank
you for being part of our patreon page
your support is not overlooked and I'm
so happy to have you here thank you for
being here and uh ooh says you're from
Texas Gabriel boy howdy
Gabrielle here's your exact address
[Music]